forging stronger ties Iranian president
Ibrahim raisi met his Chinese
counterpart Xi Jinping on the sidelines
of the Shanghai Corporation organization
last September in Uzbekistan
that's where Xi Jinping underscored
China's support for Iran and invited his
Iranian counterpart to Beijing
with Iran under heavy U.S led sanctions
more than a fifth of its exports go to
China the country's biggest export
Market
according to the same government figures
China is also Iran's second biggest
source of imports
in 2021 Iran and China signed a 25-year
strategic cooperation agreement ranging
from oil and Mining to transportation
and agriculture
is
this trip can provide a good step
towards implementing these plans in the
last 12 months Iran has exported more
than 14 billion dollars to China an
increase of 58 from the previous year
and we have imported more than 13
billion dollars from China
following the United States pullout from
the 2015 nuclear deal with Iran in 2018
and reimposed sanctions Iran has faced
the toughest economic situation in over
40 years
according to the parliament this caused
the economy between 150 and 200 billion
dollars
while Iran and China have had tense
relations with the United States they
continue to project themselves as a
counterweight to American power
alongside Russia and Ibrahim raisy's
look East policy to deepen ties with
Beijing is at the Forefront of that goal
as well as the aim of his first official
visit to China
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran